what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today John how
are you great how are you doing
wonderful guys today we are gonna watch
for the first time ever bullet train
starring Bradley Pitt and a bunch of
other famous people but before we go
into that we got a sponsor a sponsor
that we use so it always makes for the
most natural of Partnerships now if you
guys ever watch any of our horror
coverage I think it's pretty apparent
that horror is easily one of if not our
favorite genre in fact some of you may
know my passion is actually in
screenwriting and any script I've ever
actually completed is within the horror
genre so yeah Horrors my jam that's why
whenever the sponsor wants to work with
us it's always an instantaneous yes
especially because like I said earlier
we already use their service it's
shuttered come on you know it it had to
be shuttered it's Halloween time you're
like we love partnering with these guys
if you haven't heard of shutter which is
also on AMC plus let us be the first
people to tell you about it is a
streaming Channel dedicated entirely to
horror so if you're a Die Hard horror
head it is perfect and just same if
you're one of those folks who waits till
October to get some horror movies in to
start up your Halloween spirit it's
perfect for you too you can also use
promo code home h-o-m as a mother e for
31 off shutters annual subscription they
have an awesome selection of cult
classic films to iconic Hollywood
favorites in just about every sub genre
you could think of plus some really cool
playlists and original titles they've
got their own Creep Show Anthology
series they have a great documentary
called horror Noir which is all about
the history of black horror as well as
an anthology series and some of their
newest film titles include Chloe okuno's
Watcher as well as the new VHS film VHS
99 which comes out Thursday October the
20th they also have original series
airing right now including the 101
scariest horror movie moments of all
time and queer for fear which is all
about the history of queer horror
they've even got a little Christmas
horror Anthology you might just see a
familiar face and just saying maybe go
check it out everything is uncut and
commercial free and the best thing is
you can save 31 on an annual dual
subscription when you hit up our special
link in the description box and use our
promo code home support the horror genre
and by supporting shutter it helps
support the channel so it's really just
a great cycle of return on on support
alright guys let's get to it
whenever my friend pops up on screen I'm
gonna get really excited
foreign
Jesus
just what he wants to hear
cool I am ready you're getting the new
and improve me since I've been working
with very I am experiencing a calm like
never before
ladybug your new operational name oh I
see what you're doing ladybug's supposed
to be lucky
that's great look
I remember the suicidal bell boy climbed
to the roof of his hotel couldn't take
it anymore
hang in there buddy
people are considerate
oh boy
not take the gun you're gonna need the
gun against Andrew Koji I'm gonna assume
you didn't take the gun Barry says every
conflict is an opportunity for peaceful
a briefcase Intel says there's a train
sticker on the handle owners will be an
economy Club this one is plural what do
you tell me to bring that gun I did you
chose spiritual enlightenment
now Sandra Bullock's voice kind of gives
me like a gross point blank Vibe the way
they're talking back and forth I'm
trying to get his life together I got
more of a Brad Pitt in real life I've
had
coming now
oh yeah
don't taste me bro
ouch
oh my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man get a wet one on
it or something no it's not my mic no
it's not yours
together so no one else notices lemon I
think they'll notice the childish code
names first but if we can't stick with
fruit why not uh apple or orange oh so
this is a guy Richie movie yeah two bags
of birds
yeah no way I'm gonna find one brief
wait what Christopher man
jackpot your daddy I had us to get you
out of trouble you got yourself into
what is important in the 17 dead bodies
we left getting you back from the Triad
that kidnapped you with the plans to
Ransom you two extremely psychotic
father well that's a plot 16 kills mate
no 17 is six seven you're starting to
get my
16. I'll smash my name for a brick well
maybe that'll help your memory because
this is wrong with you man it was 17
goddammit
Five Guys playing poker
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that is 17. it's too easy you're
overthinking it you're underthinking it
it's not a word yes it is really did you
Google it doesn't matter
what would Barry say are this all
connected it will be go get me to
[ __ ] case hmm near reliability you
know be my father hmm
he doesn't need a reason to kill people
like you oh my god he has an accent yeah
all these boys are playing men
Leo would be proud it was trusty
oh it's not anymore
we need to find a person who took that
case maybe you're right
maybe my Lucky's starting to turn nope
nope Bad Bunny
oh that job just come back with his son
and his 10 million dollars three words
describe our situation right now do you
know what they are sure do save his son
that's more important than money right
that's making lemonade when you were in
you're in your life family you treat you
like you were one of his own you're
gonna add the blue I'm just six foot
[ __ ] six Gator from Russia
Whispers that he was exiled from the
Russian mafia there was xkgb
no one really knows the truth oh
he made his own Alliance
his own gang
wow this is awesome and beautiful yeah I
messed up at the same time this is my
favorite anime
what a cool weather loaded gun if he's
such a badass how can we hire two random
operators instead of getting to somebody
if you actually read the briefings you'd
know that you had a wife well you had a
wife yes she was the most important
thing in his life and she died drunk
driving accident or some [ __ ]
anything to hire two random operators
though and now he asked for the best he
asked for the two responsible for the
Bolivia job
wow oh my God what a thing to go to
Every cutaway could be its own movie
dude I know you're a master martial
artist
it's good then they're all updating each
other at the same time Tina in a linear
path everywhere we can follow
harmoniously explaining all this
right
so slight change your face oh
that's what makes him the wolf
so it's like Desperado
yeah this room is so much bigger than I
thought I know
Andrea
that's right did you come to your
birthday yeah yeah
look this part out of the story
there's a surprise for you she didn't
want to ruin it
mazel tov
yeah this feels very like
Desperado Mariachi Mexico all those
[Music]
oh my gosh that Breaking Bad episode wow
it's that wreck movie that takes place
at a wedding
now his whole Journey's about her
this is a superbly looking film man
[Music]
just stab me
lucky
kill my wife
pay the right taxes in Puerto Rico
oh my God is that really rapid
oh lucky
I don't know why don't you tell him
about the story about how Gordon met
Percy and how Percy's now bleeding
friends
he needs to kill him they are great
together
I was yeah I would watch each of those
cut always with them as its own movie
like I love their chemistry it's nice
seeing Aaron Taylor Johnson gonna do a
role like this in a big movie
yeah
joburg how do you recognize him yeah
from the back of his head
[Music]
ah sorry buddy I was gonna fight
about the briefcase he was in the
wedding you infiltrated in Mexico
tequila you were the cocktail server
room I knew I'd recognize that guy I'm
gonna kill his face
yeah recognize Brian to your hand I
remember God you're good at recognizing
heads in general
hello the way death would like to know
why you stepped off
your orders
I'm a professional we're making sure the
case and his son are perfectly safe
please go do my job now if something is
very kind of you
that's bold dude
[ __ ] me Jesus Christ through talking on
the phone on the train stop that hat up
your [ __ ] [ __ ] you hear me
let's see someone come by with a silver
brief coaster yeah actually yeah um a
man with black framed glasses had it he
went that way
foreign
you don't remember me
you look like every white homeless man
I've ever seen
oh you know that was there
I've always been lucky between us now
sits a wall
it's an illusion
I give you back your case you don't kill
me you give your case to the employer he
doesn't kill you I'd like to sub your
offer great but then you went and killed
someone didn't you
[Laughter]
how did you know one is early so oh no
no yeah that was gone under this table
yeah
I'll Be As Dead As that kid over there
oh damn
ah the laptop
nice some of these are like Jackie Chan
fights yeah absolutely let's think about
having the jacket earlier in the bar
[ __ ]
ing
oh
[Laughter]
come on
no no I ain't got a time a lot of
patience let alone the interest there's
an assassin in there
dude that is a hell of a laptop
don't leave your blood on the victim
yeah dude no matter where he ends up
the cutest poisoned in the same way as
he also borrow us at the wedding it's El
seguardo
call him El sabaro
oh that snake was gonna cut back damn it
the poop slang it's a character yeah
bro
CK just like a
nope oh God I was kidding uh yeah what's
up what do you need bro he was in a
movie with Sandra Bullock and Channing
tape
okay
I really blocked the sound
absolutely not
even silencers aren't that quiet tell me
and I promise I'll only shoot you up
well
um is this the sex stuff
he just always shows up for cameo
be honest
are you with a woman you're going to go
through every combination until you open
up that case I'd start with the low
numbers just a thought oh my God that'd
be so boring
my kid die
I did my best the white death wants to
make sure you're being honest about the
situation complete waste of us
all right all right we just have to
prove we have a case we don't have and
our last sign instead of a dead one what
are you thinking
we can have Bernie's
where's your twin Tangerine I'm
tangerine lemon's keeping the case safe
and the White dead Sun
yeah he's there
he's a nappy Champion chappie likes to
wave
shoot first
come up with the answers later
I always do
lemon it's a real friendship right there
you be careful too
at the end of the day they care about
each other
and that gold what is this
foreign currants
if the gun doesn't kill him the case
will I think they'll bring up in my hand
at any point no no it's a nurse unless
you fire it
but don't follow it you know what I mean
someone's gonna fire that gun in this
movie yep
he was poisoned the Assassin goes by the
name of the hornet
slang snake venom it congeals the blood
making you bleed out of every orifice
there's just the actual snake they must
have had a way to extract the Venom
lady I'm sick
[Music]
guys
[Music]
[Music]
it's her
you know what do you have uh anything
sparkling bubbles
turn it into a weapon bro I just
remember I gave all my money to that guy
to wear my hat and glasses
[Laughter]
your stand-up guy Tangerine It's gotta
be sure you want to talk this out don't
particularly
oh he paid for that water
looks like the brass knuckles are
slowing you down man yeah
he's on this train oh that narrows
damn
chopstick
you're gonna get that
shot possible
both of you this time with the case or
everyone dies
El no
game's up mate for what it's worth you
seem like all right [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I'm glad you're gonna die with me that's
nice now you guys you have more in
common than you think I already want to
see another movie with them together
you two do look like twins huh
have you opened the case yeah of course
not you know what I never asked for the
combination your main keep it safe that
way yeah
so no one gets greedy oh no no of course
God damn it look
s you nailed it
nailed it up
you wouldn't happen to have seen a tiny
white prick with a pair of glasses come
through here have you no God damn it
it's not ringing any uh have you seen a
silver briefcase with the uh train did
you say train sticker by the handle yeah
split die after shot I know
it's another weird shot for like a
really smooth one
most people assume suitcase you know
because it's a train you said briefcase
I never said briefcase you are smart I
found my diesel a room for you lemon
Brian Terry Henry watched all of Thomas
the Tank Engine for watching this is for
me
[Laughter]
number one expert you know because
within that wall shoots a window a
window of opportunity
damn it it's doors I'm finding very hard
to follow the story the point is that
door is closed
exactly come on Manchester's in there
coming yeah
you were standing in the doorway
why you should be able to read people
Common Sense tells me that this old
shaky geyser here's the one in charge
but I'm really good at reading people
and something tells me you are just not
right
so let's see here I mean I can't stop
drinking the water
you're gonna close yours and I'm gonna
count to three
and whichever one of you is in charge
you're going to raise your hand in
whichever one is it you pointed to one
who is now if you both raise your hands
or you both pointed each other I know
you're both liars and the truth ain't
yeah and then I'll shoot you where what
what what
well if I don't answer this phone you
call to kill Water free
yep
oh man
as far guys just had the shittiest day
man
there's no way
it's possible
it's hundreds of miles an hour you are
really good you sure you didn't study I
mean you're not even afraid of your lips
quivering that's a tear that is really
authentic mate like that
I got uh
you stay right there
oh no damn it hey
definitely finish that off with your
foreheads got to no new level button yep
oh man
you're my favorite
[Music]
right
oh no way I forgot she's supposed to be
in this house yeah no it's completely
forgot oh my God she's the Assassin
hahaha
yeah man Domino gets lucky she wanted
the briefcase
that face you remember
you stole my snake [ __ ]
that was really quality authorities
[Music]
you know what happens yes your blood
congeals clogging your leaves
I would promise my money
by who I don't know it was all online
they said my money was in the case
watch someone pay you to have the kid
killed this is turning into like a
mystery Noir yeah who done it bullet
train and knives out Mystery Lady you
can have the case
[Music]
oh oh yeah there's that she wants to
have some hands to do it though right
foreign
[Laughter]
do you have a backup what do you think
[ __ ]
it's a weird character yeah she says
[ __ ] a lot
that's her thing
[Music]
they murdered so many people together
it's not going to be the same murdering
people without you man
oh how wonderful I can't [ __ ] wait I
want to look into your eyes when I kill
you and your brother
oh
[Music]
they actually like did grow up together
there's a surprising amount of nuance
but other relationships right now please
just help me well I calm down get awful
dude what the [ __ ] you like you're free
to go yeah yeah yeah that's all that fun
it's like I don't know what you're doing
here anyway
ah
he was right
it's been a diesel
I'm running up and down his train
causing all sorts of [ __ ] Havoc
and it was you though [ __ ] time you
dirty little diesel
[Music]
I made lemon blade
[Music]
oh
damn it oh this is her story
uh
what
oh my God
arterial spray boy
leave it let's go let's go we gotta go
right now young lady
it's our last chance
[Music]
please ugh
[Laughter]
you're not going to let me get hurt be
honest
ly yep yeah
let's just move
and grab your back
do you have a snake at the back of his
shirt
my grandson was pushed off a roof
what makes you think I would leave him
unprotected
nice
[Music]
I'm going to tell you a story now no I'm
good it's short no no it's a good story
for you I think
I'm cool
he was not wrong but neither was I
[Music]
oh you were right
I told you so
the white death have taken everything
from me almost except for that boy
do you know what they call a ladybug in
Japan
too much I was told there is a spot on
his back for each of the Seven Sorrows
of the world
it holds all the bad luck so That Others
May
oh that's you you were handling the
death of your son in remarkably well
my son is few cause up if you could
escort him off this train yeah I don't
see the white Tesla in any other softest
train you let me worry about the white
death I mean the white death must be so
much older now
oh my goodness well now you wake up too
Brian Tyler Henry he showed to me
me too
twice
sleep he got knocked out
I want to get shot in all non-lethal
places
ah
[Music]
smart oh you drank the water
oh
what a [ __ ] my brother
oh you killed myself
to me I'll shoot you in the darkness
here at nightly we prepare together well
we die alone that's all I was trying to
say
I'll go to the driver car and get us the
[ __ ] out of here
give the man a gun if the is that
Michael Shannon
yes sir damn
completely ignored that she was on the
strength yeah
daughter
that's good yeah
I came here to kill you
kill me like you did all the others who
tried the same
hmm
do it would he be that ruthless
what happened
what about the others They're All Dead
uh good news is I have your case
hey good news
wait put two wet work operatives on a
job in Bolivia butchering my entire crew
oh in the hospital a piece of a red
piercing a
only the most skilled cardiovascular
surgeon
but two nights earlier the surgeon was
poisoned
[Music]
again got no detail on this movie is
wasted but now there is only one left
Mr Carver
I'll go in for Carver calling in sick
the man who murdered my wife
how many more surprise cameos
I'm not
[Music]
take that humongous
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh yeah it made the knife sound quieter
[Laughter]
sick this is always so brutal I don't
recall the last time I saw him in
something where he didn't have his work
I got this stop the train what whoa
yes
come on man
breaks we're good I got it
we're on the wrong track oh
foreign
[Music]
landed in water
I would not want to meet Michael Shannon
in real life
laughs
[Music]
run it down pull all the wires yep
whatever outcome you need it'll generate
that
[Music]
hey yeah I want Bubble milk too how
about a wagon wheel
laughs
[Music]
oh yeah
see how your luck pans out oh my God
it's gonna fly through every car
this is so much bigger
foreign
[Music]
of course this is so a [ __ ] it's a
mistake I'm not Carver I only do
snatching grab jobs drivers I want the
private I I had the Carver
ah come on just let it go bro
okay
oh [ __ ] I'm so glad those were his last
words
it's my luck
get delivered my father's cooked at my
feet the narcissism on this chick
needs some suggested reading if I may
surviving borderline personality
disorder what
wow BPD
before
tangerine
[Applause]
take the gun oh my god did you just say
whack we're almost there you just
she wasn't just in a voiceover booth did
you need rescuing you came to rescue me
please don't make me regret it
oh
maybe there's no bad luck or good luck
maybe we're all just agents of Fate ooh
nice car yes it is try not to bleed them
oh my God stopping peace
obviously didn't want me to have that
banana fate needs me to find a smart
toilet I take that back several of our
friends were murdered see that
oh yes
is he driving the car
go man block it off
and drinks
[Music]
nice
Andrea
boom you gotta bring her on to talk
about this now yeah full interview
hour-long Deep dive into your character
how did you prepare to be murdered and
bleeding for them how many times did
they make you throw up this Bad Bunny a
good kisser
would you kiss him again
did you ask about his tax situation in
Puerto Rico
[Laughter]
yeah man tell all all right man what'd
you think
I liked it uh it's it's one of those
movies that's really fun in the moment
that has obviously a really colorful
cast a lot of really energetic action
and is fun to watch unfold although I'm
not sure it's one of those movies where
I'm like I gotta get back and watch it
again and go and pick up all the little
Nitty Gritty details but you know it's a
bit over long and I had heard that going
in and part way through the movie I was
like I don't know I'm pretty much you
know with it and enjoying it and along
for this wild ride but then it goes on
for like an extra act and you're like
okay yeah we we have one movie on the
train kind of and then we have a movie
at the end of the line that's a sort of
addendum so yeah not perfect but I had a
lot of fun with it what did you think
yeah I thought no I thought it was um
sorry guys it's uh really late at night
right now and uh we have a situation
where one of our computers is really
bugging out so and I have to I just have
no choice but to semi multitask while
I'm talking for just the first couple
minutes into this and you'll get my
undivided attention I promise I promise
from the bottom of my heart I will not
be a major distraction so um I'm just
trying to find the part in the movie
specifically where it's at as I remember
thinking there was one part where it was
like
oh the movie's about to end yeah yeah
yeah and then I and then we have a
little uh recorder timer here yeah and
um get the for the audio and I could see
like oh it says there's something like
hour 20 but the movies those are like
two hours seven wait a minute is there
like a lot more movie left
absolutely it threw me off I'm trying to
find out exactly when that point was
um
it's definitely like right around the
time
yeah I think it's just about a half hour
too long yeah absolutely yeah it was
around the time they arrived in what was
it called Kyoto is it Kyoto yeah yeah
because yeah I feel like around the same
time I was probably thinking the same
thing like oh here comes the big final
climactic showdown on the train not not
though uh I wouldn't say that the last
half hour doesn't have its merits like
uh like I definitely wouldn't say that
like I think there's a lot of joy to be
had in that final half hour but yeah I
think it's because if this was like a
tight like 90 to 100 minutes it probably
would have been just like pretty much
perfect for what it is yeah
um but then it becomes like okay A
little overstaying it's welcome but I
still enjoyed it I still had fun like
because I mean Brad Pitt is a total
blast in this film because in some ways
he's playing type and also against type
like simultaneously so I thought that
was like a really fun performance to
watch where he is like just a he's a
badass character but he's not playing it
badass I love I love that idea of having
like a main character who is just like
[ __ ] out of luck all the time and it
makes me question like how did you get
to this high up in this position you're
a bit of an aged character so how'd you
how did you get this far along you know
how are you this good at everything even
without a gun and you have like the
shittiest luck in the world yeah yeah
it's made for fun of the amusing parts
of it I mean and Eric I think the thing
that surprised me was you know I don't
know Aaron Taylor Johnson's work too
much other than the ones that like
everyone has seen you know the Kick-Ass
films uh his small role intended
Godzilla everyone loves them I actually
really like him in God's Own
there's a lot of [ __ ] but I really like
him a lot in that film likewise and this
was the first time I got to see him
that's his actual accent right isn't he
actually British yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it was fun seeing him like play a
full-fledged character and I thought
that the the intense mannerisms that he
brought were was really refreshing and
Brian Tyree Henry the chemistry that
they they had together like Brian Tyler
Henry is actually American yeah it's the
thing is I feel like a lot of people are
probably sitting there going wow they
both do such great accents but it's
really he's got to hold up to Aaron
Taylor Johnson yeah but I thought their
chemistry was really great and I like
they imbued their relationship with some
like Nuance I wasn't expecting yeah that
I guess I like it's it's funny like I
feel like some stuff there are parts of
this movie that like because here's the
thing here's the bottom line all right
like I don't think there's an uh this
necessed like we will just because we're
talking about it
um and so why not we'll we'll go into
some you know criticisms perhaps but at
the end of the day
like the movie gave me when I fully
expected and what I wanted yeah you know
and I think that's what really counts
and I'm not just saying that to be kind
because my friend Andreas
the only reason trust nothing this man
says I would say like uh no I think it's
I think that it's you know like it has
some really entertaining action scenes I
think the cinematography is excellent
It's really hyper kinetic it's a
frenetic film and uh it's got a great
cast of characters while even though you
know not everyone gets like equal amount
of screen time everyone shows up and
they give them something to do even ones
that were I'm like I don't quite get
this choice but I'm glad there's a
choice [ __ ] like so yeah zazi beats was
one that I was like this is this is
weird and it's not what it's not working
for me like I don't like this [ __ ]
thing that they keep doing we haven't
spent enough time for this not to read
just like a cartoon yes and perhaps and
I think think that's part of what why I
think 90 to 100 minutes would have
worked better for this movie
um because
it is such a cartoon that there's real
no there's not really any Stakes because
of the fact that it's such a cartoon
yeah you know what I mean and it doesn't
really get me invested in the the world
that it's like I'm invested in the world
but the world is such a cartoon that
there's no real intensity to be had so
whenever they actually started doing
some intense stuff
for example with Joey King and Andrew
Koji I always thought while they're both
doing great jobs like don't get me wrong
they're both doing great and I love the
choice of Joey King being this Master
Alec actress manipulator I thought was
so so cool because there's something
that I brought up several times on this
channel is that I I hate in movies when
characters lie and it's so obvious
they're lying because their actors are
playing lying yeah that it bothers me
when other characters don't notice
they're lying yes exactly and Joey King
does such a great job I'm like oh you
[ __ ] it's so easy like well yeah you
can fool anyone yeah it drives up all
the tension because it's like no please
yeah we're left to sit there with the
dramatic irony of no don't trust her you
want to shake the characters and yell at
them and yeah that engages you and that
at least is effective but they do the
two of them do feel like they are kind
of in a separate movie that seems like
it wants to slightly separate not
totally separate but a movie that wants
to have those big heavy Grim stakes and
it kind of slows down the momentum of
the train it kind of slows it down a
little bit and whenever because in the
in the first part of this movie
you're cutting back between three story
lines primarily you know Brad Pitt and
like whatever random occurrences he's
having Aaron Taylor the Twins and then
Joey King and Andrew Koji are mainly
cutting between the three of them
whenever it cut to them it kind of
messed with the flow for me and and the
pacing of it for me personally so it
that was something that I was like you
know but even though it was one of the
things we're like everyone's doing such
a good job though like everyone brings
such great
character here like they're all having
such a fun time even something like
Sandra Bullock's voice over work here I
thought she was enjoying herself doing
it yeah absolutely that's something you
could easily do of just ah she's phoning
it in
she is she's not she's not for a couple
of moments but she's not phoning it in
she's actually giving a performance here
and I felt like they were actually
interacting with each other whether they
were or not I doubt it but at least read
that way yeah in the moments and uh I I
thought Brad Pitt was again uh hilarious
like the cast I think really helps
elevate a lot of this I think Aaron
Taylor Johnson what like I feel like you
were mainly gravitated towards Brian
Tyree Henry I love the both of them and
I I for me it was more Aaron Taylor
Johnson see I I gravitated toward the
both of them maybe slightly more Brian
Tyler Henry just because I've you know
have a vested intro like I've loved him
in a lot of things and it makes me
excited to see him shine in places like
this and especially you know like again
having to do the full accent having to
sell this Hitman character but I I was
just as engrossed in Aaron Taylor
Johnson because I've been a fan of his
for a while and like you like I like his
work in Godzilla and pretty much
everything I've seen him in and the two
of them together actually as much as
Brad Pitt is the protagonist it felt to
me like the movie wanted them to be the
protagonist for real because
yeah I would too and his sort of fluid
like I'm just trying to be Zen and I
don't even want to be here like there's
something and it's not even a complaint
it's just there's something about him
that feels sort of magically
disconnected a little bit from
everything and the two of them tangerine
and lemon really felt like the actual
protagonists and the characters I was
most engrossed by like every time I made
that joke joke about like I would watch
a movie about this cutaway I wasn't
kidding I was like I would love to see
these two bounce off each other as these
two guys because also too like Aaron
Taylor Johnson it's that guy Richie
styled of character that he's playing
like he's so fun to watch do that and
he's so cool you know he's cool he's
very cool and I think he brings like uh
that right level of intensity to it and
Brian Tyler Henry with the whole Thomas
the Tank Engine thing I thought was like
a stupid bit when I was first introduced
I thought I thought it was stupid but
then it started it actually worked for
me and then when it came to like reveals
and I like that they really leaned into
it because I thought it was just some
comedy bit yeah yeah they were
introducing so we're gonna do the truth
his funny little Quirk he looks Thomas
he likes kids stuff yeah I thought it
was just like some weird joke that just
was not you know cooking for me but that
even started to work and I think this
movie could have used just a little bit
I don't know if groundedness is the
right level of word I guess some type of
because while violent bloody and pulpy
it's weirdly seems like it lacks
grittiness and it doesn't really take
advantage of the fact they're on a train
and that was part of me that felt a tad
let down by because I'm like yeah you
got such a great environment to to
Really utilize some tension and stakes
and Close Quarters things and sometimes
they would do that in a fight
you know but it really
kind of got the impression you could
have done instead like any isolated
location any any one-off location yeah
and I do feel like oh a lot of the most
overt or the most broad uses of the
train are for things like when people
are on top of the outside of it when
it's going at full speed which is like
four to six hundred miles yeah so like
things like that are especially kind of
silly and heightened and I feel like
yeah they do in some ways undercut the
tension and two I mean you have this
salad of so many Hitman movie tropes and
crime movie tropes all colliding and you
have this you know huge big bad ah the
white death he's This truly ruthless
nasty character and thinking back to
something like John Wick I feel like
John Wick while those movies certainly
as they go you know Crescendo further
and further into you know fantasy there
is something about that where I felt
like that movie had that sort of edge
where I'm like the ultimate threat feels
threatening whereas here it's like I
know you're threatening because I'm
being told this and you've got a guy who
by just casting Michael Shannon at all
he already brings his imposing scary
presence but yeah the movie tonally
only really sells you on the fact that
everyone's super great at what they do
and you know it's really anybody's game
and like I appreciate that along with
the theme of luck but yeah I was never
really worried for anybody Beyond like
oh I like you or I like you uh versus
like oh man this seems dangerous or
maybe No One's Gonna Make it out like I
never didn't kind of know what was gonna
happen never felt like die hard on a
train no no no and and I think that's
something that really helps with action
movies now is if as much as like there's
some cuts on them and whatever yeah oh
they're injured but they're not really
injured like they don't play into that
especially in the finale like they don't
play into that yeah but I think that
helps it like that's what I'm that's why
I was specifically referencing Die Hard
a because of the one location but B like
John McLean is progressively getting
more and more injured as he's going and
it makes it harder to keep going and I
think that would have helped with doing
that with Brad Pitt's character
especially with the snake venom and
stuff like that like yeah to have him
with a little bit more I kept flashing
back to Jason Bourque because anytime
anyone gets beat up with the book or
whatever but like one thing those movies
not that this is the same tone but like
he did easily yeah gets more and more
banged up and more sort of you can tell
how much pain this is to keep fighting
whereas here it's like yeah Brad Pitt
goes through a lot of stuff but he's
still pretty above it all yeah you know
it's like when we're watching a movie
here where a big part of it is we're
gonna review it and then you know if we
have to we just got no choice but to be
extra observant to only be in and like
allow ourselves to just really really
observe this yeah because we're we're
here with you guys and there's gonna be
a waste of a video if it was just the
real definition of we're on a couch you
know but if I was on a couch laying down
watching this eating a pizza I'd be like
all right cool yeah it wouldn't be like
yeah it could have been better but you
know it's fun like I would have just let
it go so that's and I think that's the
main feeling that most people would
probably want with this and I think It
ultimately delivers on that you know but
from an observational from like a real
observational point I just think
sometimes it wasn't quite hitting the
mark in ways where while it was very
bombastic second and and I thought
utilized I I liked I liked when it got
weirder you know like the water bottle
moment was a great thing to do this the
traveling of the water bottle or when
they would do these crazy flashbacks
like seeing all of uh whatever Bad Bunny
characters I've seen all the bad bunnies
uh like life stories summed up in like
comic book panels and it was all mainly
visuals I thought was really cool and
allowing to mix in the genres of that uh
with hiroko's
hiroyuki
hiroyuki Sonata I believe his best work
I've seen so far was on Westworld I
think he's a man he's like I think it's
in all the first three seasons he's
amazing in it and uh yeah I think he's
he's phenomenal actor season two he
really shines a lot and um I like I
think like doing the flashbacks there so
that way you can mix in the different
types of genres is was really cool so I
think a lot of their best work was like
certain moments that were fight scenes
on the train and then of course you know
some of these flashbacks and whatnot so
yeah it was it was fun it was really
entertaining and I do think that yeah I
think this part of it was I I did find
myself sort of itching for uh you
utilize your environment a little bit
more and get get a little bit grittier
and I try to really work on selling the
stakes you know yeah I really use the
train as a prompt like I feel like there
are there are moments there are fits and
bursts like that fight they have in the
seats where they're trying to be quiet
and they're going back and forth like
that's to me the most sort of like okay
yeah you're using the really using the
invite you could have a bidet anywhere
you know you could slam somebody's arm
in a door anywhere and so yeah I would
agree with that and too like it struck
me part way through uh you know
especially as the movie started to get
longer I was like yeah I'm sure somebody
out there can make a movie that has a
tone that wants to be like this that
wants to be fun shoot em up big guy
Richie and it can last two hours and
change and really leave an impact but
part of me feels like if you're gonna
really spend all this time you kind of
have to go like the the difference
between the raid and the raid too it's
like you watch The Raid 2 and yeah like
there's all this character and stuff and
yeah that movie's not trying to be as
fun but that movie is like you can come
back to it because for the amount of
time you spend there is some heft on it
and I feel like if you're gonna spend
upwards of two hours I think you kind of
need the heft otherwise yeah this this
would have been a perfect tight 90 tight
hundred like you said and uh I think
they were trying to do that with the
Andrew Koji character they wouldn't
really do much something deeper with it
other than let's just let me introduce
him he sacked someone pushed the sun off
the roof and he's in the hospital oh
he's got the most standard of all the
stories and the most standard dialogue
like everything else is way more
colorized than his character is yeah it
feels like even his dad is more
interesting than he is yeah yeah and
they just keep cutting back to him you
know being sad while she just gives more
Exposition well she sets up mcguffins
chekhov's guns for later yeah yeah so it
was there were things that I thought
could have really pushed this to one one
of the most energy teeny movies I've
seen all year I think there were there
was qualities where I'm like ah there's
just some things that didn't quite hit
that Mark that we're always there and I
feel like David Leach does sort of
sometimes need his chats to helski no I
would I would agree with that because
like ever since he's gone off on his own
with like you know like I really like
Deadpool too a lot but that's a but none
of the action stands out to me in that
film
um I really like I liked Hobson Shaw
that you know it's just another insane
Fast and Furious movie essentially and
you know the atomic blonde had like his
best action going solo but it's not a
very entertaining film yeah not his most
returnable film yeah I feel like uh
Chad's de helski kind of balances things
out with the not the closest has come
back to in my opinion you know yeah yeah
because you do have a lot more stylized
lighting and a lot more uh fluidity and
like real composition like there are
certain transitions even beyond that one
like train smash like there's one
transition where like he's cocking the
gun and then separating two suitcases
and putting them back together like
there are some really clever visual
ideas uh but I do feel like that
tempering could take it the extra mile
because dude this is a movie that that
it it borders on that thing where it
suffers from its sort of its own assets
in a way because there's so many things
that like no element of this movie
practically except like maybe the lady
in the car shushing them like is left
unturned or or is left as just an
incidental part like everything seems
like by the end it gets paid off or or
checked back in on or it comes back
somehow and there's so much skill and
thought that goes into that and then it
kind of makes you mad when it seems like
the overall picture isn't actually as
clever as like so much of the execution
tends to be because at the end of the
day like what you're actually dealing
with it doesn't really transcend the
Trope of the story it's doing for
however many stylistic and character
flourishes it has to its you know to its
credit yeah so it's like it's it's like
a really really really well made piece
of candy yeah because it's the film I
think wants to be more clever than it
sometimes comes across yeah yeah and
wants to be Wittier than it sometimes
comes across it gets it gets close and
at the beginning it was one of those
where I'm like oh damn I gotta really
everyone's talking real fast and we're
jumping around so I can pay attention uh
but yeah like I feel like so much of the
cleverness and so much of the flavor is
more minute and more incidental and a
bit more Zen like there there are
aspects I appreciate about that but yeah
like the actual cleverness in terms of
the story and what it's about is not
really as present as some of the just
mechanical cleverness of either the
plotting or uh yeah the assembly
basically yeah I mean I think like with
the last half hour there were there were
aspects that I thought ah you know if
they hinted something more clear about
hiroyuki sonata's character having this
past
then this could have been a good
cathartic build
to when he's fighting Michael Shannon as
opposed to like let's just reserve it
all for the end and then try to make it
like this glorious moment yeah I just
learned about this like five minutes ago
you're really hitting me right now yeah
let's rely on you transferring anything
you felt for uh Andrew Koji over to
hiroyuki Sonata once he shows up yeah so
it it did miss the mark on um certain
parts that I thought it was like so it
was so close though like it was always
so close yeah and uh but it's not bad I
I want people to think that like I said
if I was just like on a couch watching
this well yeah it's like I feel like I
think it's better than like the Rotten
Tomatoes score implied yeah well this is
low wasn't it it was like in the 50s or
maybe even the 40s I feel like it was
like sometime like a 70. yeah sure yeah
yeah yeah yeah because like there's so
much to appreciate and there's so much
good work on display undeniably like
it's a great Ensemble everybody showed
up and everybody brought their a game
and his clearly having fun but not so
much fun to just plug it in John they're
clearly yeah not so much fun that
they're distracting or you know outside
the movie but at the same time you know
the fun isn't enough to make up for the
true potential the movie gives you and
doesn't quite deliver on again like I
kept thinking like I would love to watch
any of these cutaways because these seem
like they could equate to the movie
experience fully that this is trying to
be made yeah multitask give me that hard
drive back I don't know what's going on
here
we got this John no worries so this is
the best review there's a lot of
off-road reviews I mean just kind of
like the movie yeah exactly you don't
know exactly what we're doing but it
looks like you're doing something
important we're reading toward our
destination the last thing to figure out
is which of the Thomas crew we each are
that's the last one I don't watch I've
never watched Thomas oh Tank Engine dude
that's formative there's like a hardcore
fan base for it though yeah I know at
least one of our patrons is like life
dedicated yeah Bradley blood so yeah
Bradley I hey man I slept in a Thomas
the Tank Engine sleeping bag growing up
I used to watch it on PBS all the time
really Yes actually that was I mean I
haven't already started this computer to
do whatever it takes
higher further faster baby
we gotta we gotta fix this real life
right here there's more in his real life
earlier this is literally technical
difficulties in front of your very eyes
um but I don't know Bad Bunny
I've never heard his music I've met him
a few times he's all right yeah
I auditioned for your friend's part I
don't know why they didn't give me that
um yeah I've never met I've never uh
heard his music but I was like he's good
yeah I mean you know for I could have
been distracted and been like what the
hell this [ __ ] I mean oh cause he's
famous for something else that's not
acting okay if I had no idea he would
have been just fine yeah I would have
never even I wouldn't have questioned it
if I wasn't told like Bad Bunny the
performers in here I would not have a
see is he singing or something is that
what he is yeah yeah I wouldn't have
questioned it at all
um I would have just thought he was like
who's this like who's this unknown actor
see the thing is it could be
because it's bad bunny like yeah I
thought he blended into the film just
fine I thought he did a fine job but but
I was taken aback at how quickly he died
because it's bad bunny I was like I
thought you would want to at least he
his his accent and not even that it's
nothing they gave him a lot of like in
the flashback they gave him a lot that's
true yeah he had like the one of the
most substantial love like he does in
his whole life story from like when he
was a kid a mini short film about this
guy yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I heard
some people say that it wanted to be
like Quentin Tarantino but I I don't
really get that Vibe I got I got I mean
guy Richie is in a lot of ways
he's more like the music video British
Tarantino of of like the Lock Stock and
Two Smoking Barrels and snatch those
ones were like gritty and they they can
get you can get bold and especially
stats you get really Chad Brad Pitt he
really pulled into the drama of those so
yeah well I feel like yeah it feels like
tangerine and lemon are in a guy Richie
movie to me it felt like Brad Pitt was
in like an adrenalized version of Gross
Point Blank just because of how the
character is and the constantly sure
yeah exactly what it is yeah
yeah
like a more Wiggly version of that
doesn't seem brilliant but he is yeah
yeah yeah yeah unassuming Brilliance uh
and then on top of that you have uh
Andrew Koji and uh and uh Joey King who
I'm not exactly sure what Touchstone I
would put but I don't feel like they are
in a guy Richie or a gross point I feel
like they're in some weird Bland thing
they are in the traditional yeah uh uh
families Saga you know gotta avenge my
lineage blah blah you took my son I
gotta [ __ ] do this stuff Michael
Shannon looked like he was having fun
yeah I rarely say that about Michael
yeah I know right I'm rarely like
Michael Shannon's having fun in a movie
it's like good for him who's she like
look how serious Michael's [ __ ] freaking
terrifying this guys I would never want
to meet him in real life everybody just
wants to be I've seen interviews with
him and I'm still like I don't want to
meet this guy every interview I see I
feel like he's about to snap it
seems so scary just like oh God please
please ask the right question terrifying
human being even in the even in the
night before where he's like a silly
Stoner character I'm like I feel like
this guy could kill me though Anthony
Kiedis was on
yeah dude what why aren't you listening
right now
dude have you have you heard all of the
new album I have I've heard all of it
finally it's good it's great I like it
I liked a lot beautiful he had Rick
Rubin on dude it's Chili Peppers
this is all on Joe Road we got the Joe
Rogan audience yeah man take a break
from the controversy and just uh you
know dream canteen yeah all right guys
what'd you think about Andrea's
performance the best actress in the
movies killing it awesome loved it uh go
ahead subscribe leave a like and thank
you to shutter for sponsoring this vid
we got like another week
of uh October we gotta screw some horror
thing in here all right thanks guys for
being here Barbarian comes out next week
maybe we'll cover that all right we'll
see you guys soon
[Music]